you hear with reaction president Trump's
attorney former New York City Mayor Rudy
Giuliani mr. mayor you know I know the
president has been saying and you've
been saying you're not gonna testify in
front of any committee unless there's a
vote of Congress on whether or not they
should remove him but does it also have
to include the fundamental fairness
issues that Newt Gingrich gave the
Democrats in 98 it's all in here Sean
this is a great letter by PACs live
alone it lays out about eight violations
of the United States Constitution about
six violations of the president's civil
rights my civil rights attorney general
Barr civil rights
I never wanted in my life to appear to
Salem witch trial which would actually
be fairer than this is it's a process
without any due process and the fact is
it's being enabled by a completely
corrupt press corps
I don't know do you think do you think
we're going to hear on the press that a
member of the Parliament and Ukraine
held a press conference today and name
was Andre dear Koch you won't hear this
on the news
ladies and gentlemen because they censor
it you only get the news that Dems want
you to hear dare Koch publicized
documents which he said describe the
mechanism for getting money by Biden
senior this was a transfer of funds for
lobbying activities as investigators
believe to Joe Biden through a lobbying
company funds in the amount of nine
hundred thousand dollars which
transferred to the US based company
Rosemont Seneca which according to open
sources is affiliated with Biden the
payment reference was for consultative
services and then it goes on to describe
another sixteen point five million
dollar payment
apparently laundered payment involving
both Devin Archer and hunter using
political and economical levers of power
influence Ukrainian authorities and
manipulating the issue of providing
financial aid Joe Biden actively
assisted closing criminal cases this is
based on the statement today by a
parliament member in the Ukraine very
very very senior one saying that Joe
Biden actively assisted closing criminal
cases
into the activity of former
ecology Minister Mykola is low chefs key
who's the founder and owner of barista
group let me tell you who's a cola so my
colas Oh chefs key is he's a major
oligarch he stole five billion dollars
from his people he very suspiciously was
allowed to come back his case got
dismissed when they dismissed hunter
Biden's case he's the guy who paid the
sixteen point five million and the nine
hundred thousand to the Biden's or
through the but well more than sixteen
point five is more like eight million to
the Biden group this guy's one of the
major criminals in the Ukraine and he's
now walking around free because Joe
Biden got the case dismissed and this
this gentleman has said that this
information should be turned over to the
Department of Justice and for their own
purposes they should investigate it and
I'm gonna tell you why Sean because they
suspect that the president of the
Ukraine received a very major bribe in
order to tank this case I'm not saying
Biden was involved in that bribe but
it's the only thing he wasn't involved
in this case stinks they can run away
from it all they want and Sean I want
you to keep your right not just on China
I want you to keep your eye on Romania
just watch Romania let me ask you this I
hear later in The New York Times or The
Washington Post but just watch Romania
mr. mayor I have in my possession an
email from the Democratic National
Committee and this Cholula yes they do
about evidence well and I have it too
and and about they put me on a program
and I spoke to 68 investigative
journalists the date of this is May 3rd
2016 that's a working woman Sean working
with them the past yeah this is called
illegal collusion
oh but by the way it's by the Democratic
National Committee admitted because we
caught this by an operative of the
Democratic National Committee to one of
the officers of the Democratic National
Committee talking about putting OH
putting foreigners and Ukrainians in
contact with the New York Times a
gentleman by the name of Issachar
God Almighty isn't that what they said
Donald Julian didn't - mr. mayor may I
read from this if you've corroborated
this it says more offline tomorrow the
opponent you need to be aware of will
hit in the next few weeks something I'm
working on that you should be aware of
since I started digging into mana for
these messages have been a daily
occurrence and yeah speak specifically
about mana Ford and I invited Michael
Isikoff who I've been working with for
the past few weeks now have you
confirmed this from the Democratic
National Committee I confirmed it as
being one of the things that was in the
file of the Ukrainian prosecutor that
was handed over to me last January and
that I've been keeping so that I can
rebut when the swap media comes after me
and tries to attack my law firm my law
practice tries to go into my divorce
case which they're doing right now and
what I want to tell them is every time
you go after me another piece of
evidence is going to come out because
you give me a platform to get it out and
I got plenty more of this this is what
they call people evidence not lies
evidence and there's plenty of it that
Biden his son and his brother had a 30
year long scam to make money millions
selling his public office senator first
vice-president second Ukraine just a tip
of the iceberg we go to China I told you
about Romania
I got another country that I have on the
list and then we go back to all the
stealing they did when he was in the
Senate sounds like your family term
biting ink
sounds like you back it sounds like a
Rico investigation back in your old days
in the Southern District I got my advice
I actually don't know I actually don't
know much about the RICO case oh I think
you do actually yeah I don't know much
about Rico I think you do mr. mayor
thank you we'll have you back regularly